I first met you once turned alive when
we both worked there yes and I
remembered one night you and I just went
out and we did karaoke I don't know if
you remember this but you and I went out
we did karaoke yeah amazing you sing
like Elvis better than just about
anybody I know and and and I was doing
my Jerry Lee Lewis and the two of us
kept taking turns I had the long
sideburns back then big hair and we
killed it in that karaoke we did and we
were the only ones who thought so it was
good it was the highlight of my life
it's all been downhill since then but I
think it every now and then I think
about that I also think about the time
that you came on our show in the early
days and you did a conceptual bit that
was so funny where you were dressed as
Superman Jervis and II and then at one
point you elevate and you come flying
over but you get stuck we pretended that
you get stuck right here when you
weren't but you just pretend to get
stuck and then you're there the entire
rest of the show and so other guests
would come out and sit underneath you
and remembered Mayor Koch the mayor who
was that had been the mayor of New York
was just looking up at you and the mayor
you were like opinion you were just
there and we would try to keep the show
going and it was this weird theater well
when when the mayor passed away I was
very upset that it wasn't mentioned in
his obituary
you